philosophy for our times is brought to
you in partnership with the new college
of the humanities a university liberal
college offering undergraduate and
postgraduate degrees in the heart of
London
NCH pride themselves on offering
unprecedented access to a world-class
academic faculty philosophy students of
the college are taught by some of the
foremost scholars in the field and
one-to-one tutorials create a
personalized teaching experience choose
your major and minor for a unique
combined honours degree and study the
NCH diploma to widen your appreciation
of the world in ways you'd never thought
of before go to NC H London dot a C dot
uk' for more information think better
think NC h-hello a welcome to philosophy
for our times the podcast which brings
you the world's leading thinkers to
debate today's biggest ideas we're here
to question whether perhaps playing the
strong man on the world stage and being
unpredictable might actually make the
world a safer rather than a more
dangerous place from peace talks to
trade agreements the norms for brokering
peace seem well established however this
week our speakers question whether the
belligerent foreign policy of leaders
today suggests a change in the rules of
the game for achieving global peace our
war and peace turning out to be two
sides of the same coin
we're talking mainly about Trump who I'm
sure lots of people in this tent think
is a bit of a buffoon but paradoxically
perhaps his foreign policy is actually
achieving something from the Iran
nuclear deal to peace in North Korea
will Trump's foreign policy be looked at
in the future and lessened in
manufacturing peace oh this is a sign of
more troubling times to come take you on
the state of war and peace today we have
and former Labour MP and founder of the
respect party George Galloway and
co-founder and director the European
Council on Foreign Relations mark
Leonard as ever please do get in touch
and tell us what you thought of this
week's episode head over now to iTunes
and give us a rating and review to let
us know what you thought tell anyone you
know that might be interested and of
course have a look at a whole host of
episodes which are available from
philosophy for our times back now to
Marion seek arts who hosts this week's
episode does that sort of policy a
strongman policy unpredictable slightly
crazy policy make the world safer or
more precarious so George's
cannibal ignorant foreign policy lead to
stability in the world like we've never
tried that before in fact the world is
in chaos precisely because of a
belligerent foreign policy and sometimes
the belligerents are mad like Donald
Trump bad like Tony Blair imbecilic like
George W Bush but they were all
exponents of and practitioners of a
belligerent foreign policy and the
results are there for all to see the
question seems premise on the assumption
that we have had a non-belligerent
foreign policy at any point in modern
history in fact since the United States
was born it has been a war all but one
year all but one year in its entire
lifetime and the last time Britain had
no soldiers fighting abroad and only
briefly was in 1779 so we have had not
just a lifetime of but centuries of
foreign policy belligerence and it
doesn't flow from any
go Pathak character necessarily although
some like Richard Nixon in his
belligerent foreign policy was
undoubtedly psychopathic like his
foreign policy guru seems to have been
the guru to many including the
aforementioned Tony Blair Henry
Kissinger were undoubtedly psychopathic
but it doesn't necessarily require that
it requires a view of the world that the
rich and powerful have the right to
dictate to the less rich and less
powerful the the people who can do if
you can conquer other people's countries
in the past or conquer their economic
reality if not their territory as
happens more often nowadays if you can
you do and that's why we have chaos and
violence and the threat of truly
unbelievable levels of violence in front
of us today you asked Marianne about
Trump and his foreign policy let's
review it Trump has unilaterally
withdrawn from the Iran nuclear deal
signed Salomon binding by his
predecessor and the permanent 5+1 and
the Islamic Republic of Iran and
impeccably I'm using the words of the
IAEA impeccably observed by Iran Trump
has unilaterally withdrawn from it
begun a raft of ever deep and punishing
economic sanctions against Iran and
yesterday a major terrorist atrocity was
carried out by Saudi sponsored which
means American sponsored terrorists in I
was in
which killed 26 people now not just
soldiers but old soldiers paraplegic
soldiers members of the public in the
crowd and journalists covering the event
we are headed potentially to cataclysmic
conflict again in the Middle East what
could possibly go wrong
Iran will undoubtedly respond extremely
violently against Saudi Arabia at any
minute
certainly not long-delayed that will be
get a response and so the spiral towards
war will twist Pompeo the US Secretary
of State the former head of the CIO CIA
this week threatened actions against
Venezuela they've already got sanctions
almost uncountable number of them now
it's us actions against Venezuela that
we can expect in the next few days and
the elephant in the room the morass of
the Syrian war some of you know me from
my stand against the Iraq war I'm here
to tell you that the involvement of
Western countries in the Syrian war is
the worst thing we have ever done ie
worse than Libya worse than Iraq our
belligerent foreign policy of arming
financing propagandizing for Isis al
Qaeda and the alphabet soup of Islamist
fanaticism in Syria is the worst thing
that we have ever done and
notwithstanding that the war is almost
over we may very well be about to double
down to
double our bets on the catastrophic
conflict in Syria
so can a belligerent foreign policy
bring about peace and stability in the
world not bloody likely
[Applause]
thank you George right over to you mark
so I agreed with the last sentence that
George uttered but I do think that
there's a fundamental problem with the
way that he laid out his case which is
that he's normalizing Donald Trump and
just putting him into a continuum of
Western foreign policy over the last few
decades but I think the reason we're
having this debate is that something
quite fundamental is happening there is
a fundamental disruption in Western
foreign policy which is deeply troubling
and deeply worrying and one of the ways
that you can see how much the world is
changing and how quick the chaos which
Donald Trump has unleashed is going
through our our political systems our
international institutions is the fact
that even Donald Trump jokes getting out
of date very quickly during the election
campaign in Conan O'Brien quipped the
70% of Americans were deeply worried
about the idea of a trump presidency and
30% were becoming Canadian but if he was
making the joke now he'd realized that
the last thing anyone want to do is to
become Canadian because Donald Trump
seems to have a particular animus
against America's northern neighbor and
sees it as one of the worst foes of the
American system and I think the reason
for that is that he has a fundamentally
different worldview from President Obama
President Bush Bush the father clinton
reagan or any of the other presidents
that have been in power at least in the
last hundred years and i think there's
three things which are unique
me worrying about Trump as president the
first is that he is the only u.s.
president in my lifetime who has seen
the International order as something
which undermines rather than enhances
American power in the world and I don't
think that he thinks that that order
doesn't benefit the West and benefit the
US but he does think that it benefits
others more in particular China and his
starting point is that if he does
nothing at all he will be the president
the overseas the relative decline of his
great nation and that China will become
the most powerful country in the world
because every year China becomes
stronger and richer and the u.s. in
relative terms even though it grows is
is becoming smaller and he but he thinks
that the entire establishment and the
elite is so wedded to this order in this
way of doing things that it's incapable
of reforming it and therefore what I
think he's trying to do is to launch a
process of some Puteri and creative
destruction where the first instance is
to blow everything up with a view then
to renegotiating the order on terms
which he thinks are more beneficial to
the US because he thinks the paradox of
the status quo is that America is paying
a lot of money is losing a lot of lives
in order to sustain an order which is
helping China more than America and
that's why he's blown up the jcpoa drr
nuclear deal which George was talking
about why he's trying to blow up the
World Trade Organization why he's
threatening NATO why he's withdrawing
from almost everybody that you can think
of in the United Nations um it's because
these are part of an order which he
thinks the u.s. is trapped in which
constrains it and above all in his very
zero-sum mind these are all institutions
which empower the week over the strong
and America is the strongest than the
most powerful country in the world so
therefore any institution which brings
countries together to negotiate with the
u.s. is one which in relative terms
weakens the US and strengthens other
countries against it and that's why
these institutions
to be destroyed that's why he talked
about the European Union as a foe and
even though we are the closest allies of
the US and have been for decades because
he thinks that we you as it was designed
to weaken the US and to strengthen weak
European countries and then I think
stage 2 in this process of shrimp Atari
and creative destruction is to try and
renegotiate an order on bilateral terms
where the US deals with every single
country on a one-to-one basis so it can
do it from a position of strength and
make the new order
cheaper and less constraining but the
impact of that is really to to destroy
all of the advances which have been made
in the last few decades and I find
George's characterization last few
decades is very strange like my mother
is a German Jew she was born in exile in
in France most of her family were wiped
out in concentration camps
my father is British but his earliest
memories of being evacuated as an
eight-year-old during the Second World
War his father got gassed in the First
World War the fact that my generation
and my kids who are sitting in the front
can look forward at a sort of world
where the idea of war between European
countries is unthinkable where they can
travel without showing their passports
from one country to another and where we
have law-based controlled ways of
dealing with disagreements between
countries is it's an incredible advance
I don't want to minimize the catastrophe
of the Iraq war all the all of the other
mistakes and belligerent act of Western
foreign policy over the last few decades
but we live in a completely different
world it's a world that is being
threatened by Donald Trump and by what's
happening at the moment and that brings
me to the second threat of Donald Trump
as president which is the fact that
going back to my Canadian example the
people that he feels the greatest animus
to our American allies because they're
the ones who are propping up the system
the most so he thinks that they are the
number one enemies in his process of
disrupting the global order that's why
he's much more comfortable dealing with
Vladimir Putin or Kim jong-un than
dealing with Angela Merkel and the fact
that he's undermining u.s. alliances
means that every single part of the
world where order has been based on
alliances with the United States is
becoming much more unsafe that's true of
Europe it's true of Asia it's true of
the Middle East and what's happening is
two things are going on as American
alliances become questioned and people
don't know whether they can count on
normal Trump to back them up the
American allies are having to hedge
against being abandoned by the United
States so they're having to rethink
their options to rearm and to up their
military spending at the same time the
enemies of the United States its rivals
also wondering whether the US is going
to back up their ally so they're testing
out how far America will stand by its
allies and they're also encouraged to
rearm and to behave in belligerent ways
so in every theater of the world what
we're going to see over the next few
years and new levels of instability new
levels of violence and the the problems
which George Galloway was talking about
in the Middle East and not about Western
foreign policy and us arming relatively
dysfunctional groups in Syria it's about
the fact that there was an order which
was guaranteed by Western powers which
has now disappeared and that's created a
space where Iran and Saudi Arabia and
others who were held together in place
by a system and now testing out their
power and fighting death and nobody
cares about what they're doing and no
one's trying to stop them and there are
no limits on the instability which can
happen as a result of that and the third
thing which I'd like to end with about
Donald Trump which is something which I
don't think we should normalize either
is not him as an individual his
unpredictability his misogyny his racism
and all the horrible and disreputable
functions of Donald Trump but it is the
philosophy which he embodies which he's
a symptom of the idea of trumpism and
that is a cancer which has taken hold in
all Western developed societies where a
large number of people who feel that
they've been left behind by established
politicians and by established political
parties who do not feel that they've
benefited from me advances which I
described earlier and actually rather
than seeing a world of greater
opportunity
they feel threatened by a lot of the
infrastructure of the globalized world
whether it's free movement free trade
and they feel nervous about their nature
the culture of their communities
changing the economic circumstances
their job security being changed in a
world where the west and the developing
that developed countries feel that
they're being kind of marginalized by a
rise of of others and that that's coming
into our own societies and that plays to
a politics of what is called the
political science is called the
threatened majority where the people who
felt that they're in power now worried
that every other kind of minorities
being mobilized against them and
therefore a ripe for manipulation by
political figures whether it's Faraj in
this country Donald Trump in America
mainly been in France the FDA in Germany
and if these political forces succeed to
work together as we've seen happening
with with salvini in Italy and all ban
in Hungary they're not just going to
turn our own countries into much less
safe and and comfortable places to live
but they could actually join Donald
Trump in dismantling this global order
which has made my lifetime much more
comfortable much safer a much less
threatening than that of my parents or
grandparents
it looks like I'm gonna have to play
devil's advocate here so if you are
America and you have been the leading
member of NATO for the past whatever it
is sort of sixty odd years
santiago and you have spent twice as
much of your gdp sometimes three times
much of your GDP on defense and you've
watched the other european members of
NATO free-riding on your defense
expenditure don't you have a right to
say come on guys shape up pull your
weight absolutely I mean I think
Europeans need to take responsibility
for their own affairs we have achieved
incredible things in our own continent
in the last few decades and it's only
been possible because this remaking of
the European order has been done under
an American security blanket which
Europeans have not paid for I think in
the early years and decades after the
the Second World War as someone from a
German Jewish background I think it was
probably healthy for Germany not to be
spending five ten percent of its GDP on
defense but I do think in the long term
it's obscene for three hundred and fifty
million Americans to be paying for the
security of five hundred million
Europeans there were as rich as them and
our interests are not the same and
Trump's actually showing how dangerous
it is for us to put our security in the
hands of the incumbent of the White
House not because America is a uniquely
evil or dangerous country in fact you
know if any country was going to be a
superpower of velocity decades I think
we Americans do one that I would most
have wanted to be in that position but
we're seeing whether it's over the Iran
nuclear deal whether it's about
Jerusalem as capital of recognizing
Jerusalem as capital of Israel whether
it's how we deal with Turkey our
interests are not identical with
American interests and if we don't take
responsibility for our own affairs then
we'll find ourselves unable to to do
things which are which are right for our
societies or and also to stand up for
the kind of rule-based order which
Europeans believe in
so I agree with the critique that
Europeans should spend more on European
offense so we need a more kind of
grown-up relationship with the US where
we're dealing with the more as equals
but I think that the amount of money the
US has paid for towards NATO velocity
that it's very cheap compared to the
amount of money that American citizens
taxpayers had to pay to get involved in
World War one in World War two or during
the Cold War where they were dealing
with Europeans being kind of belligerent
being at each other's throats and having
more kind of militarized societies so
I'm not sure that his solution to the
problem is is one which will actually be
in America's long-term interests but I
do hope that Europeans take this as a
wake-up call because the world is very
very fragile at the moment it's not just
Trump it's Xi Jingping in China it's a
Diwan in Turkey it's Putin in Russia
there is a universalization of this kind
of strongman foreign policy and the
world around us is becoming much much
more unsafe and if we really believe in
what we've managed to achieve over the
last few decades then we need to stand
up and and be willing to defend it and
that can't just be with great speeches
or even by taking out economic sanctions
against people who are threatening that
order I think ultimately we have to have
the full range of tools and that
includes military power George well as
half an irishman I'm entitled to say as
the Irishman apocryphally did when asked
the road to London I wouldn't have
started from here the exceptional
ization of Donald Trump to which you've
just been listening is absurd Donald
Trump's been the president of the United
States for less than two years did the
chaos in the world start less than two
years ago it's utterly ridiculous the
crooner your idol
nice suit Barack just
loyd Libya and turned it into a slave
market and a jihad market for at least
seven heavily armed different Islamist
groups wasn't Trump that did that was
Obama that did that you have the goal to
pray and eat George W Bush is somehow
better than Donald Trump George W Bush
and your other hero Tony Blair killed a
million people in Iraq and rising
spawned Isis cascaded across the world
you see how happy how smug you are about
the rules-based society that we had
before Donald Trump 23 months ago 22
months ago
where was the rules-based order in the
invasion and occupation of Iraq and
utterly illegal act the consequences of
which will still be feeling in a hundred
years from now where was the rules-based
in the destruction of Yugoslavia no
international law no United Nations
Security Council unilateral use of
Western power deployed by the people
you're trying to persuade us were better
than Donald Trump
Vietnam was leveled bombed back to the
Stone Age
drowned in chemical weapons by Richard
Nixon and by Lyndon Johnson they were a
part of this rules-based complacency of
which you speak and in aid of your
argument you draw attention to the fact
that populist SAR coming to power the
populist SAR coming to power precisely
because of the failure of your
international order precisely because of
the failure of
you're authored oxy it's because
neoliberal politics totally filled in
Italy that you have the government in
Italy you have ditto in Hungary ditto
the rise although it stopped now you may
have noticed that melon shone with whom
I agree in every particular is now the
most popular politician in France not
lepen she's gone off for psychiatric
treatment the the rise of Trump the rise
of carbon the rise of the right and the
populace in Italy are all because of the
failure of this order which you so
smugly wish to return us to I don't
think it what about foreign policy
charge to be honest the reason these
populist have been so successful is
because of domestic discontent
economy average voter on the doorstep
who's voting for Donald Trump is not
talking about Syria they're talking
about really the reason for the rise of
the populist in Italy is why because the
country has been flooded by millions of
refugees from the wars begun by your
heroes first of all let mark joins
himself as long as me already I think I
think you're both getting a very fair
crack right I might spike him for longer
but I wasn't accusing you of worshipping
heroes that you didn't worship so maybe
I can sort of try and take a step back
from your very powerful rhetoric and say
first of all the fact that we can talk
about breaches of the rules-based order
like what happened in Iraq because you
called it a mistake no it's a breach
it's a million people dead for God's
sake this is a rally this is it
died of sanctions beforehand according
to people who were criticizing it before
Saddam Hussein killed many many people I
was against the war in Iraq and I'm
still against the war in Iraq nothing
has happened over the last 15 years to
change my mind about that but I think is
the very fact that there was an order
that we can recognize that as a breach
of the order now what makes me slightly
uncomfortable about your rhetorical
flourish is that you put all of these
different things which are quite
different on the same level you know
what happened in Vietnam will happen in
Iraq being put on the same level as
intervening to stop genocide in Kosovo I
find strange they're not you know not
every type of use of violence I think
using violence is always bad but
sometimes it's the least bad option
I think the second world war was
justified given what Hitler stood for I
think intervening in Kosovo was
justified in order to stop a genocide
and where lots of innocent people were
being that's what you said in Libya well
I was not particularly bein war I think
with hindsight what we can see is
genocide and Libya genocide in Kosovo
I'm not sure exactly if everything's
genocide then it basically normalizes
the idea of genocide for me you stop you
stop tossing out about them once about
my family that was actually wiped out
well you said there was no general side
in Kosovo there was ethnically and
people blessed no genocide well yes
thank you you got a microphone on you
don't need to shout okay so I I do think
that it's important not to toss words
like genocide about it's also important
not to put every single foreign policy
decision that you disagreed with on the
same level there there is the fact that
there was a rules-based order means that
we can see the breaches of that order
and that is what's being destroyed and
to see I I hated George Bush he was my
least favorite
American president until Donald Trump
was was elected I was absolutely
disgusted by I wrote a whole book
against Bush's foreign policy back in
2004 but at the same time I do think
that he was a fundamentally different
figure from Donald Trump because he
basically believed in the existence of a
rule-based order and he was pushing to
change it Donald Trump wants to blow the
whole thing up and to bring us to a
stage of AG of Anarchy where the only
thing that matters is the law of the
jungle and where the strong decide what
happens and the weak have to do what
they tell them to do and I don't want to
live in in that world and I think if you
can't see the difference between those
two situations and you just normalize
Trump and put him into some kind of
continuum of betrayal which goes back
you know centuries like you did
beforehand and everything is genocide
and every military campaign is equally
bad then it's impossible to have a
serious discussion about what we're
trying to do in this world I do think
that they've been all sorts of mistakes
made over the last few decades I'm a
social democrat I'm not a neoliberal I
think that a lot of these populist
parties are coming to to power because
of a failure of domestic politics I
think some of the leaders like Jeremy
Corbyn are there because the failures of
foreign policy there would be no Corbin
if there hadn't been an Iraq war that is
clear to me but I think it is important
to try and hang on to what what matters
in these things because if you're not
you end up in a kind of nihilistic place
like where everything is equally bad and
where the solution is where you just
sort of have nothing constructive to say
about anything because everyone is a war
criminal everyone is equally evil
everyone is is it's kind of genocide or
and that completely undermines any
critique that we have of what's
happening at the moment which i think is
really worrying and scary and needs to
be stopped
can we talk a bit more about what what's
happening at the moment in relation to
North Korea which is something we
haven't mentioned yet so some people are
saying okay a few months ago three or
four months ago we were worried about a
nuclear war in North Korea
now we've got Kim jong-un meeting with
the president of South Korea deciding to
a bid to host the Olympics together
agreeing to denuclearization and that
that is down to Donald Trump's tough
foreign policy know what I mean I think
his foreign policy has worked incredibly
well on one country in the world and
that's China I was in China a few weeks
ago and was very struck but they see
Donald Trump a completely different
terms to how he's seen in the West most
of my American friends and all of my
European friends see Trump as you
described it at the beginning as a kind
of buffoon who's self-defeating and kind
of destructive and doing all sorts of
things which which undermine American
interests and I do a kind of fundamental
level as I said in my first answer but
at the same time in China they think
that he he's both our kind of master
strategist and a master tactician but he
basically pushed they think that he's
been declaring war on them on kind of
three fronts on an economic front on the
kind of political front and an
ideological front and they use North
Korea as the kind of prime example where
he ups the ante creates a real sense of
crisis puts the Chinese government under
so much pressure to introduce sanctions
that they shift their position six or
seven times he they get to the point
where the North Koreans almost see the
South Koreans has kind of sworn enemies
their closest allies with the only
country that they have a treaty
relationship with and then when he
realizes that he's run out of Road he
shifts tack basically tries to do a deal
and and then opens up a new front with
the Chinese on trade which we're now on
at the moment and I think actually you
know having seen various different
presidents and lots of Europeans fail to
make any headway on the Chinese there is
some kind of logic in terms of how he's
handling with China is he helping on
North Korea and I think it's much too
early to tell I'm happy that they're
talking rather than him threatening to
you know tweeting about Rocketman and
threatening pre-emptive nuclear strikes
at the moment but I do worry that
as a result of mistakes in in Western
foreign policy over the last few decades
we created very perverse incentives for
the for the North Koreans having seen
what happened to Saddam Hussein to
Gadhafi I think it's quite difficult to
see why North Korea wouldn't want our
nuclear weapons and why a North Korean
leader wouldn't want to have any clear
Hawaii trust
Western assurances that we will not try
and change the regime if if they get rid
of their nuclear weapon so I'd be amazed
if they really do do that and then
ripping up the Iran nuclear deal exactly
the moment that you're trying to do a
deal with the North Koreans on nuclear
weapons seems like a inexplicable and
sort of catastrophic decision so we'll
see what happens I also worry that if
this fails is it's quite likely - it
will then empower the Hawks like John
Bolton within the administration who
want to go back to using military
solutions against North Korea and I
think that is the the scariest thing so
I do think we have every incentive to
try and make this work as much as
possible I think that you have very wise
leadership being shown by the South
Korean authorities they have been trying
to handle and to manage Trump but
they're in a very risky position because
they exposed themselves enormously and
Trump is totally unreliable and
unpredictable and that could be another
big casualty of this affair but I think
you know the time to make pass judgment
on his on his North Korean diplomacy is
probably in sort of five or six years
time rather than at the moment yeah okay
so George we've heard a very passionate
denunciation from you of the rules-based
international order can you tell us what
you think should replace it Donald Trump
is an unpredictable unstable person he's
not strong and stable genius he's a bull
in a china shop and to mix the metaphor
even a stop clock is Right twice a day
and he was right to meet with the North
Korean leadership and he was right to
encourage a rough
between North and South Korea and it's
going swimmingly
in fact it's practically a love-in the
Koreans are embracing each other with a
warmth and vigor that no one could
possibly have imagined and Donald
Trump's predecessors would never have
permitted this is important
Barack Obama would never have met Kim
jong-un and therefore the permafrost of
North South Korea relations would have
continued so and not only would Barack
Obama not have done Hillary Clinton
would not have done it and so if we are
looking objectively at this thing you
have to see that Trump was right about
Korea and the others were wrong because
Korea has been for decades a Kree a
clear and present danger to world peace
and and stability it's not I'm
passionately denouncing the rules-based
international order I'm passionately
denouncing the fact that there is no
rules-based international order you just
called lawlessness a rules-based
international order with some mistakes
some breaches but how many breaches does
it take to invalidate your thesis in the
first place
if you have what you call an
international rules based system in the
world which is not just reached not just
mistakes but which kills millions of
people and renders the whole world
completely unstable how many times does
that need to happen before your thesis
is invalidated now for most people it
long ago ceased to be credible to call
it a rules-based international order and
I refuse to accept your thesis that's
all I haven't got a thesis I'm just
asking you to what you think
that there is an international
rules-based oh I see and my case is it's
abundantly clear that there has not been
and that therefore attempts to
exceptional eyes Trump which is the
liberal mantra and nonsense he's only
been in 23 months so if we have the
morals in total chaos before he came so
so if we hadn't had the United Nations
and NATO set up after the Second World
War
do you think the world would have been a
better place I believe in a United
Nations with real authority but as long
as you have veto powers it cannot
possibly guarantee international order I
support the United Nations it's it's
Tony Blair and George W Bush that walked
out of the United Nations and caused the
Cataclysm which is being I think
underappreciated here of the Iraq war
not since the first world war did we
take a decision that would so change the
world as the decision to invade Iraq now
the United Nations did the late Kofi
Annan described that at the time as an
indigo act and yet it was carried out by
people who pretend that they are
presiding over a rules-based
international order lost lost point mark
you know we're going round in circles a
bit but what happens is that there's a
certain point where utopianism becomes
nihilism if you say that the order is
not perfect that there all sorts of
things wrong with it and therefore it's
the same as having no order at all
that's a circular argument from my
perspective I think it's better for us
to have an idea about what kind of order
we want to live in it's something which
you have to fight for it you're fighting
against the laws of history for most of
human history there has been no such
thing as the rule of law we've lived in
the kind of jungle where might makes
right and over the last century
they're in fits and terms they've been
attempt to try and bring some kind of
structure to try and regulate the
relationships between countries it's not
been a linear process it looked like
there was a lot of progress a hundred
years ago and then we had the Second
World War and then the Cold War but
after the end of the Cold War
I think enormous advances were made in
protecting human rights in setting up
institutions to deal with the climate
crisis to deal with genocide to make
sure that you didn't have trade wars
between different countries and it's
imperfect and it still allows hypocrisy
and it's easier for strong countries to
get their way than weaker countries and
there's racism and there all sorts of
horrible things that have happened and
I'm not defending any of them but I
think that the attempt to do it is
something which is no ball and is
worthwhile and is something that should
be supported the fact that we are trying
to do it also allows us to see where we
fall short of those of those aspirations
and there are lots of examples of it
countless examples of it but it doesn't
mean that we shouldn't keep trying and I
do think that Donald Trump is not just
somebody who's behaving outside of that
system he's acting against that system
and trying to destroy it and that's why
he is a kind of unique threat to what
has been achieved over the last few
decades and I think he should be called
out as that rather than just seen as
part of a kind of history of lawlessness
and to pretend that this project hasn't
been there and that these institutions
are not there even if they are often you
know undermined and we don't live up to
them but the very fact you can talk
about any legal act means that there's a
law thank you
thank you very much to both of you thank
you all for coming thank you so much for
listening to this episode of philosophy
for our times this podcast was brought
to you by the Institute of Arts ideas it
was hosted by me and I Carrie and I
guess this week mark Leonard and George
Galloway as ever please do subscribe to
make sure you never miss an episode
tell anyone you know that might be
interested and of course tune in next
week for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you